John McCain is linked Barack Obama to  unrepentant domestic terrorist Bill  Ayers and asks do you know enough to  elect Barack Obama but how well do we  know John McCain from us 30 years he's  proudly gone to work every day with a  rogue's gallery of the worst elements in  American society this side of a Dick  Tracy comic strip ranging from Senator  Robert Byrd the former exalted cyclops  in the Ku Klux Klan there are white  [ __ ] to Senator Larry Craig the  totally heterosexual toilet cruising  Casanova from the great state of Idaho  the bad boy bill clinton you're a  naughty boy to Senator John F Kerry who  oversaw the brutal torture of college  students don't tase me bro to Senator  Barack Obama who consorts with known  terrorists why would John McCain work  with someone who is friends with someone  who bombed the Capitol do you know  enough to elect John McCain